[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Siri schönen guten Abend ja
weiterhin Unruhe beim DFB mehr dazu
später mit dir Christine und etwas
Bundesliga guten Abend und das haben wir
heute außerdem
immer mehr Flüchtlinge erreichen Europa
in Deutschland gibt es Streit über eine
Obergrenze für geflüchtete
üben für den Ernstfall unter deutscher
Führung trainieren in der Ostsee
Soldaten aus 14 NATO-Ländern die Bündnis
Verteidigung
ein Peaks gegen Corona seit heute können
sich Risikogruppen mit dem angepassten
Impfstoff Boostern lassen
[Musik]
die Bilder von Lampedusa am Limit
erzeugen viele politischen Druck Italien
verschärft jetzt seinen Kurs etwa mit
einer Verlängerung der Abschiebehaft für
Migranten und auch in Deutschland wird
über härtere Maßnahmen diskutiert im
Wahlkampfmodus formuliert Bayerns
Ministerpräsident Söder eine ältere
csu-losung nämlich die einer Obergrenze
für Asylbewerber das Thema Asyl und
Migration bleibt umstritten auch
innerhalb der Ampel Lars bodensack
manche Kommune in Deutschland kommt
langsam an ihre Grenzen die
Flüchtlingsheime sind voll weitere
Aufnahmen schlicht nicht möglich die CSU
schlägt Alarm und bekräftigt ihre
Forderung nach einer Obergrenze von
200.000 Flüchtlingen pro Jahr gibt es
keine Lösung gibt es kein Handeln
besteht auch die Gefahr einer sich
destabilisierenden Demokratie deswegen
braucht es eine gemeinschaftliche
politische Handlung und er tätig zu
werden es braucht eine
Integrationsgrenze die ampelparteien
lehnen eine Obergrenze ab und verweisen
darauf dass sie bereits zahlreiche
Maßnahmen eingeleitet haben wir machen
die Politik von Frauen die
Migrationspolitik von Frau Merkel
rückgängig und erzielen und müssen auch
sehr schnell hier konkrete Lösungen
erzielen eine konkrete Lösung wäre für
SPD und FDP auch die Maghreb-Staaten zu
sicheren Herkunftsländern zu machen doch
da sperren sich die Grünen dass die
Maghreb-Staaten also Staaten in den zu
systematischen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen kommt für uns
ganz klar dieses Etikett nicht haben
können die Innenministerin betont dass
es in diesem Jahr bereits 27 Prozent
mehr Abschiebungen gegeben habe als im
Vorjahreszeitraum und verweist auf die
Verantwortung der Länder ansonsten muss
man natürlich die Maßnahmen für die
Abschiebung auch verstärken für die
Menschen die leider nicht bei uns
bleiben können Abschiebung werden in den
Ländern organisiert für die Linkspartei
sind viele Forderungen vor allem dem
Wahlkampf geschuldet sie lehnt
Obergrenzen und andere
abschottungsmaßnahmen ab wollen wir das
wirklich eben ein Europa das sich mit
mauerstacheldraht und am
Schusswaffen gegen geflüchtete zur Werse
das ehemalige wir schaffen das ist links
einer großen Skepsis gewichen und die
Parteien Ringen auf offener Bühne
Theo Koll in Berlin wie viel Sprengkraft
hat das migrationsthema sowohl für die
Ampel als auch für die Union also ich
glaube das Thema hat enorme Sprengkraft
und zwar für den ganzen
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt in der
politischen Handhabung dann auch für
Ampel und Union Deutschland ist ja
wieder fluchtland Nummer 1 in Europa
viele Gemeinden sind überlastet und aus
der Politik kommen vor allem eher
ratlose Signale auch deshalb hat hier im
ZDF gestern Bundespräsident ARD Joachim
Gauck gefordert nicht nur an alten
Stellschrauben zu drehen sondern auch
klar zu machen dass das humanistisch
wünschbare nicht immer umsetzbar ist und
die Grenzen der Leistungsfähigkeit
erreicht sind die AFD macht sich die
Lage zu Nutze und wird ein immer
wichtigerer politischer Faktor vor Ort
müssen die Parteien aber dann damit
umgehen und rennen wie jetzt in
Thüringen kommt durch die Brandmauer von
Friedrich Merz oder lösen tektonische
Verschiebungen aus wie ist der SPD-Chef
jetzt nennt am Ende aber geht es da nur
um Versuche mit den Auswirkungen zugehen
wichtiger wäre es an die Ursachen zu
gehen also warum wollen in mittlerweile
vier Bundesländern über 30% der Menschen
AFD wählen und da scheint es
migrationsthema ein Teil der Antwort zu
sein vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
nach berlin-koll
der Herbst steht vor der Tür und mit ihm
die impfsaison seit heute gibt es einen
angepassten Wirkstoff gegen Corona die
Infektionen die haben ja zuletzt wieder
zugenommen weswegen der
Gesundheitsminister bestimmten
Personengruppen eine Impfung empfiehlt
mehr von Christel Haas und Anna duda
ein Bundesgesundheitsminister sollte
auch immer Vorbild in Sachen Gesundheit
sein Impftermin im Bundeswehrkrankenhaus
in Berlin Karl Lauterbach ist 60
geworden und zählt damit zu den Personen
für die eine Auffrischung empfohlen ist
die kovid-infektion ist keine Erkältung
das ist keine Kleinigkeit und es können
auch weiterhin bleibende Schäden
entstehen zum Beispiel onkowith die
coronazahlen steigen wieder doch es gibt
eine breite Immunität sagen Experten
impfen lassen sollten sich daher nur
Personen ab 60 Jahren solche mit
Vorerkrankungen Angehörige von
Risikopatienten und das Pflege und
Gesundheitspersonal für sie ist die
Impfung kostenlos als eine der ersten in
Rheinland-Pfalz hat diese Hausarztpraxis
bei Mainz den neuen angepassten
Impfstoff erhalten die Nachfrage hier
ist recht hoch viele Patienten sind
besorgt über die steigenden corona-fälle
das hängt damit zusammen dass diese drei
Mal Impfung damals sicher war aber heute
eben den Omegon Varianten nicht
einschließt und deshalb ist die jetzige
Impfung so ganz besonders wichtig
Hausarzt Friedl Rohr hat schon eine
impfliste die erste Dosis bekommt Birgit
Riese sie arbeitet in der Praxis für
mich persönlich ist es wichtig dass ich
geschützt bin um andere dann nicht
anzustecken
kontaktbeschränkungen soll es erstmal
nicht geben auch wenn die positiven
Fälle zunehmen Corona wird da ein Teil
sein aber natürlich auch die Grippe aber
auch andere Erreger werden natürlich im
Herbst und wirken im Winter zirkulieren
im Zweifel Maske tragen sagt der
Gesundheitsminister noch und appelliert
an die Eigenverantwortung jedes
Einzelnen
wir haben vertiefene Informationen zum
neuen Impfstoff und Corona in unserer
ZDF heute erfinden sie antworten auf die
wichtigsten Fragen zum Beispiel wie
gefährlich neue Varianten sind
der cum-ex-skandal hat den deutschen
Staat Milliarden gekostet seit heute
steht eine der zentralen Figuren vor
Gericht nämlich Christian oliarius als
Chef der Hamburger Warburg Bank soll er
cum-ex-geschäfte abgesegnet haben dabei
wurden Aktien ja hin und hergeschoben am
Ende wurde die fällige Steuer nur einmal
bezahlt aber vom Finanzamt mehrfach
zurückerstattet besonders brisant ist
das Verfahren auch weil der Name Olaf
Scholz fällt mehr von Christoph
Schneider
umgeben von vier Verteidiger erscheint
Christian olearius im Landgericht Bonn
der 81-Jährige Hamburger Bankier soll
die verbotenen Geschäfte nicht nur
abgesegnet sondern auch initiiert haben
Angeklagte soll bei 13 Fällen in den
veranlagungsjahren 2007 bis 2011 als
Hauptanteilseigner als persönlich
hafnergesellschafter und Sprecher der
Partner eine Hamburger Privatbank
sogenannte illegale cum-ex-geschäfte
gegangen haben es geht um einen
steuerlichen Schaden von knapp 280
Millionen Euro Überstunden zeichnet die
Staatsanwaltschaft in ihrer Anklage ein
detailliertes Bild eines abgestimmten
Systems bei dem allen Beteiligten
bewusst gewesen sei dass die Profite der
cum-ex-geschäfte gerade durch
unzulässige Steuertricks entstehen
nachdem das Bonner Landgericht schon in
anderen Fällen des cum-ex-skandals
Haftstrafen ausgesprochen hat muss sich
nun erstmals ein ehemaliger hochrangiger
Bankvorstand vor Gericht verantworten
der Fall wird aber auch wegen seiner
politischen Verstrickung Fragen auf
Stichwort Gespräche zwischen olearius
und dem heutigen Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz Fragen die in diesem Strafprozess
aber vermutlich keine zentrale Rolle
spielen werden trotzdem fiel der Name
Schulz auch bei der Anklageverlesung
olearius hatte damals wegen der
steuerlichen Nachzahlung Kontakt zum
damaligen Ersten Bürgermeister von
Hamburg gesucht Treffen an die Sie
Scholz nicht erinnert
weitere 28 Verhandlungstage hat das
Bonner Landgericht bis Ende März
kommenden Jahres angesetzt
sind die und Roma in Deutschland sind
sie immer wieder Anfeindungen sogar
Gewalt ausgesetzt ein erster
Jahresbericht hier zu zählt für
vergangenes Jahr mehr als 600 Fälle auf
der Beauftragte der Bundesregierung geht
zudem von einer hohen Dunkelziffer aus
ein großer Teil der Diskriminierung in
dem Alltag statt etwa im Wohnumfeld und
bei Behörden darunter auch die Polizei
Vorfälle können inzwischen online
gemeldet werden
es ist ein Deal zwischen Erzfeinden die
USA und Iran haben einen
Gefangenenaustausch vereinbart in den
Vereinigten Staaten werden fünf Iraner
begnadigt und im Gegenzug kamen fünf
Amerikaner heute frei sie landeten am
Nachmittag in Katar des Golf im Iran war
an den monatelangen Verhandlungen
beteiligt Iran bekam außerdem
fünfeinhalb Milliarden Euro überwiesen
Geld deswegen US Sanktionen eingefroren
gewesen war
nach einer Äußerung von Außenministerin
bärbock hat China die deutsche
Botschafterin eingestellt am Donnerstag
hatte bärbock im TV Interview mit einem
US-Sender Chinas Staats- und Parteichef
Ski als Diktator bezeichnet die
Regierung in Peking hatte zuvor von
einer offenen politischen Provokation
gesprochen
die UNO Mitgliedstaaten beraten diese
Woche über einen höchst ehrgeiziges
Anliegen wie kann angesichts der
aktuellen Krisen eine bessere eine
gerechtere Welt erreicht werden schon
2015 haben sich die Vereinten Nationen
17 Ziele gesetzt etwa die Beseitigung
von Hunger und extremer Armut die
Begrenzung des Klimawandels sowie die
Bewahrung natürlicher Lebensgrundlagen
und die Förderung des Friedens das Meer
soll bis 2030 verwirklicht sein aus New
York berichtet Elma tewesen
Olaf Scholz soll mithelfen denn die Zeit
drängt und die Welt erwartet von
politischen Anführern mehr
Entschlossenheit der UN-Generalsekretär
fordert nichts weniger als einen
Rettungsplan für die Menschheit 2015
hatten die Feinden Nationen die Ziele
für nachhaltige Entwicklung beschlossen
aber jetzt liegen gerade mal 20 von 140
Maßnahmen in Feldern wie Armut
Gesundheit Klima
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit im Zeitplan es
soll nun einen Schub geben mit konkreten
Finanzierungsmodellen für die
notwendigen Projekt
wir können es schaffen wenn wir jetzt
handeln wenn wir gemeinsam handeln und
wir unser Versprechen gegenüber
Milliarden Menschen halten deren
Hoffnungen Träume und deren Zukunft sie
in ihren Händen halten
sie machen Druck 10000 forderten zum
Auftakt der un-woche die Abkehr von
fossilen Brennstoffen Taten gegen den
Klimawandel und für mehr Gerechtigkeit
in der Welt
diese Woche ist ein kritischer Moment
für den ganzen Planeten für das Klima
müssen wir jetzt handeln ja
sie sollten die Erde beschützen aber sie
tun es nicht
das soll sich ändern mit Milliarden
Geldern für Projekte vor allem in den
Ländern des globalen Süden dass wir mit
unseren technologischen möglichen Kiten
mit unserer Wirtschaftskraft die
Rahmenbedingungen dafür schaffen dass es
möglich ist wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand
zu gewinnen und auszubauen und
gleichzeitig klimaneutral zu
wirtschaften es wäre ein riesen
Fortschritt auf ähnliches hoffen viele
wenn sie ab morgen hier über den
russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
beraten
denn das gerade gesehen in New York
schlechteres Wetter als bei uns dort ist
MRT Wissen Elmar Vollversammlung in
angespannter Weltlage Stichwort Ukraine
Krieg was ist da in dieser Woche noch zu
erwarten
ja bei der Versammlung morgen werden der
US-Präsident der ukrainische Präsident
und der deutsche Bundeskanzler
gewissermaßen im Gleichklang auftreten
sie werden den Respekt fordern für
territoriale Integrität und Souveränität
das ist dann die Adresse Russlands
gerichtet am Mittwoch wird sich der
Sicherheitsrat auch mit dem Thema
Ukraine intensiv beschäftigen selensky
trifft auch Scholz und auch beiden
jeweils einzeln und wird am Donnerstag
in Washington erwartet beim
amerikanischen Kongress wir gehen davon
aus dass diese Woche noch ein neues
waffenpaket für die Ukraine beschlossen
wird mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit mit
weitreichenden Raketen aus den USA den
attackens vielleicht auch mit Raketen
wie eben den Taurus Systemen aus
Deutschland und man hat hier schon den
Eindruck dass Russland isoliert ist als
in der Vergangenheit und das hat sicher
damit zu tun dass der Ukraine kriegt als
der große Bremsklotz auch für die
Erreichung der
Nachhaltigkeitsziele empfunden wird über
die man sich ja heute noch einmal
verständigt hat vielen Dank für die
Information
en aus New York el Matthi wissen
ja Stärke zeigen in der Ostsee vor dem
Hintergrund des Krieges in der Ukraine
da trainieren zurzeit Nato-Partner unter
deutscher Führung den Bündnisfall
northern coast heißt dieses Großmanöver
das vor der Küste Estlands und Lettlands
läuft mehr als 3000 Soldaten aus 14
Ländern rund 30 Schiffe und 19 Flugzeuge
Proben im Ernstfall eine mögliche
Seeblockade durch Russland Andrea Maurer
es ist ein brisantes Szenario alliierte
Streitkräfte üben wie sie die Ostsee
gegen Russland verteidigen können
wichtige Handelsroute und Seeweg zu den
NATO-Staaten im Baltikum
dieser Übung hier in einem sehr
strategisch wichtigen Seegebiet ist es
auch gleichzeitig von nato-seite eine
abschreckende Signalwirkung gegenüber
Russland zu senden mit unserem
Einsatzkräften machen wir klar dass wir
schnell flexibel und rechtssetzungsfähig
sind sollten wir den Glauben sein dass
die Sicherheit des Bundesgebietes
gefährdet werden
russische Aufklärer beobachten die Übung
aus sicherem Abstand das Manövergebiet
liegt in der Nähe der russischen Exklave
Kaliningrad wo große Teile von Russlands
baltischer Flotte stationiert sind
abschrecken aber jede Provokation
vermeiden eine heikle-mission
Wachsamkeit Bereitschaft
Einsatzfähigkeit ist ja grundsätzlich
nichts was aggressiv ist sondern das was
die russische Marine Marine hier in
Ostsee genauso macht auch die zeigen
Präsenz wir zeigen Präsenz für die
deutsche Marine bedeutet der Einsatz
auch dass sie sich neu aufstellen muss
bislang war sie zuständig für
internationale krisenmission die Flotte
ist geschrumpft jetzt will Deutschland
mehr Verantwortung innerhalb der NATO
übernehmen
etliche Einheiten sind überhaupt nicht
mehr für einen Seekrieg ausgelegt von 24
U-Booten beispielsweise gibt es gerade
mal noch sechs die Umstellung die
Rückbesinnung auf Landes- und Bündnis
Verteidigung für die Marine ein Kraftakt
Schiffe der deutschen Marine bleiben
nach der Übung vor Ort oft nur wenige
Seemeilen von Schiffen der russischen
Marine entfernt
gestern standen der Kanzler und die
Politik im Zentrum des Verdi
Bundeskongresses heute ging es bei der
Dienstleistungsgewerkschaft ums Personal
der Bundesvorstand wurde gewählt und der
Chef im Amt bestätigt Frank Wernicke
bleibt Vorsitzender für die nächsten
vier Jahre der 56-Jährige bekam gut 92%
der Delegierten Stimmen eine
gegenkanitur kann die Natur gab es nicht
in Berlin haben Mitglieder der
sogenannten letzten Generation am Morgen
wieder den Berufsverkehr blockiert
betroffen waren mehr als 20 Orte vor
allem Autobahnabfahrten und
Bundesstraßen einige der festgeklebten
Aktivisten konnte die Polizei erst nach
Stunden von der Fahrbahn ablösen in
Prenzlauer Berg besprühte ein wütender
Autofahrer die Klima Kleber mit Reizgas
und soeben kam noch diese Nachricht der
Sänger Roger Whittaker ist tot wie
mehrere Medien melden nach dem nach
starb er bereits am Mittwoch im Alter
von 87 Jahren Roger Whittaker wurde in
Deutschland besonders in den 70er Jahren
populär mit Hits wie Albany und später
mit schön war die Zeit sein
Markenzeichen sein britischer
Zungenschlag und seine Sohne
und hier geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
Sport und wir beginnen Christi mit
Fußball gesagt mit der Bundesliga am Tag
nach der umstrittenen roten Karte für
Darmstadt Thema wegen Handspiel ist beim
3-3 gegen Borussia Mönchengladbach
sperrte dass die DFB Sportgericht den
Verteidiger für eine Partie
die Szene die das Spiel dreht kurz nach
der Pause verursacht mathema Glitzer
einen Handelfmeter und sidrot bis dahin
für Darmstadt souverän 3:0 maglica mit
dem zweiten Treffer für die Lilien noch
vor der Pause erhöht Tim skarke
die Gladbacher Aufholjagd in Überzahl
startet Jordan in der 56 Minute Florian
Neuhaus bringt endgültig die Hoffnung
zurück
und Thomas schwantara lässt es zum 3:3
entstand krachen
und alle Tore und Höhepunkte des vierten
Bundesliga Spieltags gibt's bei uns auch
online auf der ZDF heute.de und in der
ZDF heute App erste Arbeitstag für den
neuen Geschäftsführer des angeschlagenen
Deutschen Fußball-Bundes Andreas Rettich
auf den äußerst anspruchsvolle Aufgaben
warten wirtschaftlich und personell es
brodelt an vielen Stellen
da ist er der neue Andreas Rettich ein
kleines Beben begleitet seine Berufung
Bayerns Karl-Heinz Rummenigge und Oliver
Menzler von RB Leipzig fühlten sich
nicht eingebunden sind aus der Task
Force zurückgetreten und Verständnis
beim Präsidenten es hat in diesem
Gremium nicht ein einziges Mal den
Wunsch gegeben über die Geschäftsführung
im Bereich Sport zu sprechen zudem hatte
die Task Force nur beratende Funktion
aber Andreas Rettich polarisiert er
steht für mich für ein Perspektivwechsel
und den präzisierte neue Geschäftsführer
wir müssen sehen dass wir
ein bisschen flapsig nicht nur die
Portemonnaies erreichen sondern auch die
Herzen eine komplexe Aufgabe nicht
einfach in diesem Umfeld
echt viel Trubel beim DFB allerdings
vielen Dank Kristin zum Wetter so viel
kräftige Schauer mit Blitz und Donner
sind unterwegs Details hat gleich den
terli um 21 Uhr 45 das heute journal mit
Dunja Hayali ja das war es von uns
morgen an dieser Stelle hier jana pareig
ist danke fürs Interesse und auf bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja die erste
Septemberhälfte war schon deutlich zu
warm und eine richtig durchgreifende
herbstwetterlage stellt sich nicht ein
auch wenn es jetzt durchwachsener wird
mit schauen und Gewittern die ostwärts
ziehen dabei kannst durchaus eine Nacht
im Südwesten stark Regen geben aber sie
sehen ja auch ist lockert auf hier diese
hellen Farben das bedeutet es gibt
keinen Regen morgen Nachmittag im Süden
schauen wir uns die Details an in der
Nacht also schauen und Gewitter teils
kräftig auch im Osten das zieht alles
allmählich ostwärts ab und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 9 Grad im
hessischen Bergland 16 bis 17 Grad an
oder und nice und morgen dann im
Südosten noch schaue die allmählich sich
verabschieden ansonsten neue Schauer
gibt's im Nordwesten und dazu auch
kräftigen Südwestwind teils mit
Sturmböen bei höchsten Temperaturen von
24 Grad z.B im Osten Deutschlands und 18
an der Nordsee die nächsten Tage am
Mittwoch ist es trocken bei Temperaturen
bis 27 Grad noch etwas wärmer am
Donnerstag mit 29 Grad dafür aber neue
Schauer und Gewitter und damit ein
schöner Abend